Okay, so we are doing so as in the past few years you just have to get things in.
My name is Kenneth Hedberg and this is a 20th of October 19th of 2011.
Okay, so yeah, I would like to start with you telling us about the role that you played
in the following papers telling you what you say.
Yeah, well, we talked about that last time, I guess.
Did we have to be known as, oh no, well, I have a comfortable feeling on repeating myself
here, but maybe not, the effort to bring the papers here began when I sat at the head table with
the Helm Paul enduring a meeting short in celebration of the awardee of the Pauling award,
which had been newly set up by three sections of the American Chemical Society.
And she told me at that time that people, several universities and other institutions were
after Linus's papers, but she said, he didn't want them to go to these institutions.
She said, they didn't want all of his papers and the University of Pennsylvania, I've seen your
remember as one of them, as well as Caltech and Stanford, they only wanted to select proportions,
but they wanted them all together, and so she said to me that she had felt for a long time
that the papers ought to come to Oregon State. Now, this was before pulling relations with Oregon State
had been repaired, and she went on to remark that she'd been talking to him and she was trying
to persuade him that he should let bygones be bygones. So that was that Linus later.
Oh gosh, that was the early 60s. I'm sorry, my memory is easy on these exact dates,
but anyway, sometimes there. So I conveyed this information when I got back to the
institution to President of the University, with that time was a Johnson. He called me and asked me
if I thought that pulling would accept an invitation to come to the University of
Spain speak. And I said, well, it could well be the case that doesn't do any harm to try.
Now, have I outlined the reasons before? Well, the pulling did not want to come to the
institution. Well, I thought we talked about that. That's odd because, well, never mind.
In the late 40s, there was a faculty member at Oregon State, named Ralph Spitzer,
who was denied tenure in the Department of Chemistry. He was an excellent physical chemist,
and he raised the issue that he was being fired for his political beliefs, found that
partly on a letter that he had written that was published in chemical and engineering news,
not supporting, but at least saying that people ought to at least think about what this
fellow single, and at that time, the Soviet Union was saying about the effect of
environmental inheritance. And of course, it's included in the face of conventional wisdom of
the time that everything was inherited. So at any rate, the faculty of the chemistry department,
decided that they would not offer him permanent tenure, which meant, of course, that he had to leave.
Now, I knew all the members of the chemistry department having given an undergraduate here,
consequence of those was that Ralph Spitzer asked the American Chemical Society for hearing
the issue of, forgotten what the ECS committee was, but anyway,
the idea is that you're not supposed to be discharged from a teaching position on grounds
of your political beliefs. And at the 1948 meeting of American Chemical Society in San Francisco,
which I attended, Ralph made his case, and he was strongly supported by Linus Pauling.
The Upsolu always was that I don't think the ECS committee wanted to get its hands
to deeply involved in this thing and not much ever came of it, but Pauling was rather actively
pursuing an ocean that Spitzer was a fine scientist, and it could be no reason that he shouldn't be
kept on for a professional reasons. Well, Al Strand was president of Oregon State at that time,
and the news media, or some media made it, well, there's knowledge of what Pauling had said,
and Strand got properly angry and said, well, Oregon State can get along without Linus Pauling.
And Linus Pauling, then, said to the media, when this was reported to him, if they can get along,
about Linus Pauling, they will. So from 1948 to all through the 50s, and of course, they won
as Nobel Prize in 1954, and these pies laid around. Yeah, nothing to do with Oregon State.
But after Mrs. Pauling's comment to me, and my relay of this information of Johnson, he called me and said,
what, as I said before, I would call him except an invitation. And due course, this was tendered to him, and he agreed.
But he was going to come here, and he was not going to speak, he's going to speak to the university as a whole,
not going to speak to a chemistry department on scientific subject. So there was a huge meeting held in the present,
guilty, I'll see him. And there was a podium set up on one side of the floor, and Strands were filled on the opposite side,
as his kind of a stage. And the head of time, Johnson, excuse me, asked me if I would introduce Pauling.
Well, if you think about that, here's a distinguished scientist coming to speak to the university,
and the present of the university is not introducing him, an ordinary faculty member like me was asked to do so.
Well, in my presence, Pauling, and I, and Johnson and maybe some other people were there, Johnson and Pauling,
that I was going to introduce him, and he turned to me, and he said, you're going to introduce me,
can, and I said, yes, he's asked me to do that. Pauling didn't say a word, but it was perfectly clear,
but he felt that it was appropriate for the university president to do the introduction.
Well, so anyway, all of Mrs. Johnson and President Johnson and either Hill and Pauling and Lioness and Lisa,
and I got in the limo, and we're sure for over to the whole same. And everybody was sitting there waiting,
we filed in and went up on the stage, and a few things were said, and then I rose to give my introduction,
which I did in a few minutes and about this time, this is Pauling was about to speak in a file,
the group of students, they were all black, and many prominent among them were many members of the football team.
And this is at the time, when the great punk and the degree that football players were not going to be able to wear beers,
and at that point all hell broke loose, and there were meetings on the campus regarding free speech and the ability of the students to put both hand and have a personal care,
and so as they wished, and the great punk and assisted that, he finally resulted, I think, to say,
that the beers didn't fit very well with a helmet and so on. And anyway, in due course, these people, they set a few words,
and then they turned on a abruptly filed out, and very well behaved, and so Pauling gave his speech,
which was on peace, and very well received, and so on. And then at a dinner that evening,
Pauling said to me, she said, oh, I was so surprised, she said, I thought all these blacks that had filed in,
with her, where they were going to sing. Oh, well, that was the beginning of several
lectures to Pauling. He came back on succeeding occasions, but in the middle of all of us,
well, not in the middle, but I think at the beginning of all of us, I had reported to Johnson
that Pauling thought that Melanos's paper should come to Oregon State, and of course, that would have been a great coup,
and so he, gingerly, boasts the subject to Pauling. I wrote him a letter about this, actually,
and Pauling, in due course, responded and saying that, oh, he would give it some thought that he was not yet prepared to give up his papers,
because he was still actively using the materials that were in them. And after Johnson retired,
he was succeeded by the picker, and I didn't think to great deal about this, Pauling was now coming and going,
in a case, and then suddenly occurred to me that I should follow the information that I had given to Johnson to him as well.
So I dug out the correspondence letter that I had written, and President Johnson's response to it
and typed another letter and sent it off to Dr. McPickery. Well, this scenario was repeated,
and he, again, occurred Pauling on his paper. This was now some several years later after the first overture,
but he got the same response back. Pauling wasn't yet ready to park for these papers.
And time went on, and John Bern making President. And once or down, I hold out these papers,
now I'll have two sets of correspondence and wrote the John, sent it off to him.
And his response was a little bit different, immediately set up a committee on which I served,
and he made a concrete offer to Linus Pauling at the others having it. He said,
we are very, I'm paraphrasing him now. You could talk to John and find out exactly how this went,
but the gist of it was that he said that they would create it, and they would not just
set up a room or something or create a special collections in which he could, all of his papers
could be housed. They would build this for him. I think you see, I only see these facts from
what I remember of our contacts, but I should be checked with John.
Remember the committee was Rob Phillips and some others who may can't remember now.
But anyway, this went on, and this time Pauling agreed. This is what would transpire,
but he wanted also other homes papers to come as well. He strongly felt always liked that after
he had won the peace prize that she should have shared it, because she was the one that actually
stimulated his activity in that area. Well, there was a huge, a huge degree to do this.
The first thing that he did was supply to the university, and you'll know all this and the
records of the Special Collections. He sent the copies of the signatures to the proposal for
the way of all the petition for banning exploding explosion of nuclear weapons in the atmosphere,
atmospheric test bands. And that was the first thing I believed that came to the Oregon State.
And only graduated the other materials appear still, because of course,
when I was Pauling was acting until shortly before his death.
And I remember, excuse me, people here were not
to clear about how big this collection of Pauling was. And so, the due course of the university
suggested our Paulings suggested that they come down and take a look at what he had.
And the Christian Dorothy was sent down. And he came back and told me,
I'd kind of cross as far as I should be, since there were over 90 filing cases.
Now, in that big circle, we're falling head as ranch. You see, all the stuff had been moved
down there. And he said, Christian Dorothy was just totally blown away by all of this.
Well, in due course, after Pauling had agreed to give his papers, there was a very, very
elegant reception and Portland with several speakers and lavish dinner.
It was really a very, very nice affair and Pauling spoke. And that stage,
somehow the question came up about all of his materials coming here and there had been some
of the family members, particularly Linda, I think, who felt that the family should have held
control over some of these, and Pauling was asked, well, what does your family think about all
this? And he says, well, Linda's here, why don't you ask her? I don't remember what a response was,
but I do remember Pauling's statement very clearly. Well, as time went on,
these things began to arrive, these filing cases, now remember, I'm not sure,
describing to me a truck and pull up and disclosure to these filing cases and so on.
And that was a start and we had that saw the project through to completion. I don't know
when the last of these materials actually arrived here in special collections, but that's kind of
the history of how they came here, at least of the role that I played in and doing nothing but
reminding one person and after another of what Pauling had, what Mrs. Pauling had urged
and to do in the fact that the relations have been repaired, send it between the university and
the last Paulings and the suggested things might go smoothly forward from there. I do know that
he was actually very fond of the university, but he came on business, which he did not
infrequently, I usually somehow involved in escorting him around walking the campus with him
and a number of occasions we walked around campus for one time, we walked up in the old
who was in those days known as a chem shock and then quite seriously remodeled from Pauling's
time, but he seemed to be able to pick out the room in which he had been lecturing when they
even Helen Pauling had appeared in his life. And we walked down 15th street, and he showed me a house
there that he had lived in as a student and I said to him, it's rather surprising.
It was a certain parallelism in our experience here because I lived on 15th street also only
on the other side of the street just to have a block down when I was an undergraduate student.
So I took a picture of him and Linda on the steps of the house. I have it somewhere in my materials at home.
So, the other thing I would say is that when Pauling began to come back to Oregon State on
occasions, we saw him in his life as long as she was living quite frequently at home for dinner
and places and things like that. So we got to know them pretty well, better than when I was a student.
Of course when I was a Celtic as a student, I was a student. I was a student. I was a student.
So it has been for me a wonderful exhilarating experience.
So does that answer your query? I've spent 20 minutes describing it.
Well, I'm interested in not very giving it a memory of giving it a memory of the times that
either home and minus become an engineer and you have to remember.
Oh yeah, sure, I have, I have, I keep thinking that I have said
some of this to you before, but it may have been to somebody else, but let me think just a moment.
One time, this is an a music anecdote and I don't know whether it involved Rob folks,
but I don't have the host laws for a dinner party that the Paulings and we were invited to
along with Dave Schumacher, who was chairman of our department and who, by the way,
in Pauling very well. He was a student at Caltech when I was and we all knew that Pauling
and he didn't shy away from alcohol, he liked the vodka and on the evening of the dinner party
and just before about four o'clock, I got a call from the host. Sorry about my throat
asking me, I know the Dr. Pauling likes vodka since I looked at my cupboard and I don't have any
and I don't have any way of getting it. Do you happen to have any vodka? And I said,
well, as a matter of fact, I do. Am I told this story? No, well, I sort of met a fact I do,
so I went into my cupboard and I had maybe two thirds of a bottle there and so I got a brown
paper bag and put the bottle in it and then we were picked up and the Paulings were picked up
and we were driven up to the whole house, Ryan Dorbell and he appeared and everybody shook hands
of he and it is why I've greeted everyone most closely and as I walked in I had a dim my paper bag
and put that bottle in it and then everybody settled down for a bit and living room before dinner
was served and the whole said, well, what anybody like a drink and Dr. Pauling said, well,
you don't happen to have any vodka to you and the whole said, well, as a matter of fact, I do.
So I thought that was that story I think is very funny on retrospect and then he wrote
I never told Pauling this is true at all. So I have to read Helen died, he continued to come
to Oregon State, often with Linda as a company dim and they would come, there were lots of things
up at the University of Reception Zero, there was a big library reception one time and there were
seminars in chemistry and even in physics and then usually after these affairs and before dinner
well, I say usually that often at any rate, he and Linda would come to the house and
one occasion I'm referring still, he's enjoyment of a drink before dinner, he came down.
We were on the campus walking around and I said, what would you like to do now before the next
reception which is a hour and a half life? Is this as well? Can we go to your house for a drink?
Can I say yes? We could, so we went over to my house and he said, you don't happen to have any vodka?
I said, yeah, I kind of thought, I know you like that. And so I got a glass, a small cup of
liquor, put some ice in it and he drank a drink straight vodka and it's essentially pure alcohol,
you know, and he told me at one other occasion before dinner, he always said one of these
cocktails what that was about it. So I opened the glass and started to pour and I said, say,
well, he didn't say well and the thing was full, I stopped and he looked out and he wrote a smile.
There was a lot of ice in it so it really wasn't an awful lot of vodka, I think, at any rate,
we chatted a while and then he said to me, can I have another? And Linda was sitting there and
they had to go with this as a time, we had to go to reception over here in the library,
someplace or another, a library reception but it was held in the M.U. and one of the rooms at the
M.U. And anyway, he says, can I have another vodka? I'll put some more ice in it and pour it again
and once again, I stopped when I was full and Linda was over there and said, daddy, daddy, you shouldn't
do that, you've got to go to a reception. Well, he just smiled out and then we got up and walked out
and he walked straight as a rod, he didn't waver at all, we got in the car, we're over there and
he walked in and he shook hands with people, you couldn't tell and you know, he didn't weigh
an awful lot, he probably weighed 165 pounds or 60 pounds or something, he's a tall man and
loose jointed as everybody knows it and that the reception will not just find. At one dinner party,
we had a misappalling with still alive, we tried to set it up in a nice fashion, we had
another, there were the Paulings and Lisa and me and another couple of me, I've been
two more, maybe eight people, but we had a first course with some white wine and I brought out the
bottle of them and poured the wine on, wine has picked up the bottle, what does it say? Oh, he says, yeah,
this is, I can't pronounce this, well, we say and he says, that's the same wine you served us last year,
but why he would remember of all of the dinner parties, it's been to what wine we had saved him
at a dinner party a year before, beats me, but anyway, that was his remark, it's been great fun knowing
and so does that answer your question about the papers and so on? I want to ask you about the
she makers if we have their questions, yes, I should like to tell you, you've ever seen it abroad,
what do you call it and what they're like, there's people in this thing. Oh, well, Dave's
you maker and I were close friends and when they reserved on a national committee together,
the United States, the American Crystalographic Association has a committee on which, well,
at any rate, we have a meeting to which I travel in Washington DC and Dave's you maker was a
chairman of this committee, well, he and I had been students at Caltech and I knew him very well,
and at the end, before I left, we were looking for a replacement for a Burke Christmas and
who is retiring and there was some talk given about bringing in, in fact, it was preferred to
bring in an outside person and I was a press of how Dave, who is an MIT, is professor of chemistry
and a crystalographer, ran this meeting, he's very efficient, I thought, hey, he'd be a good
chairman and so the meeting was one run under a very, very tight schedule we had, we worked
furiously for several hours and then people had to disband and they were not having a dinner,
they were going to go home so I had almost, I said, Dave, I'm going to talk to you and he said,
well, he says, you know, I got to catch a train and so that's not such a time but he says,
I'm on the way to the restaurant, let's go to the restaurant. There, well, this may sound
an delicate and when you play it back again, but there we were on a pair of urinals,
which were at an angle to each other, so we were somehow facing each other and I outlined this
situation to him and asked him if he would consider, I think about being considered as department
chairman, of course Dave grew up in Idaho, went to read college so he loved the west and although
MIT was a very prestigious institution and they had a summer house, he had a plower up in
the mountains, he said, yes, he would think about it. So he came out and people liked him and
he was off for the job, well, one of the conditions for the job from his point of view was that
his wife Clara Brink was also a distinguished crystallographer and she wanted to be able to work
to have an appointment. At that time there was a law, in fact it may still exist that came
into being during the depression. There was an anti-nepotism law and it decreed that no members
of the same family, I don't remember how that was defined, should work in the same department
or in fact in the same institution but even further in the state system of higher education,
except under unusual circumstances. Well, about this time, Lisa, my wife who has also
signed us, we've been working together for years and we had a joint grant together and previous
to that, she had had appointments in the computer centers and associate professor and so on.
So she was a professional but then it was determined that by Bert Christensen
that he wasn't going to allow her to work any longer and be paid. And so I went to him and said,
look, we've got this grant here and then you've signed it on the bottom, the line item on the budget
and Lisa has to be able to work. He says, I'm not going to approve it. So we took it over to
a virtual room, who is Dean of Science at that time, bought it in, I showed him this and he says,
well, what did she tell me this sooner and I said, well, Bert Christensen, he were very close
friends and I thought we should be talking to the chain of command here and he says, well,
he says, here is a document that's legal. He says she's going to be able to work on this grant
until it expires but after that she wants to continue to be paid, she'll have to be
get a grant of her own. Well, all this approach, the Dave coming in one of his conditions,
as I say, was his wife be allowed to work. And unless he's heart, McPicker came around and he
looked at this and he says, okay, he says, it says that you cannot have members of the same family
working in this institution at the same time and being paid except under unusual circumstances.
He says, it's clear that a husband and wife scientific team is an unusual circumstance.
So he says, I am going to approve this. And then Dave said, yeah, but Ken Hedberg and his wife
are exactly the same situation and McPicker says the same room applied on him. Then McPicker said,
and this is very funny. You're a Dave and I are close friends and our wives are friends.
And McPicker says the only thing I'm going to ask is that you be responsible for this
in my wife and Ken who would be responsible for Clara. So once a term, Dave would call me in
his office, it says, okay, Ken, how is Clara doing? And we would have a big laugh. Well, I said,
fine, I said, how is Lucid doing? Fine, he says, that's it. So that's the history of
without condition. Dave accepted the job and was here sort of that capacity for some years until
he retired and then he and Clara had an office in chemistry. But he became ill with the kidney disease.
Funny was on dialysis and died of a heart attack on time during dialysis over an Albany.
Clara lived for several years after that and they set up a fund.
Anchored with $100,000 to begin with for the support of students in chemistry. So that's Dave's
shoemaker. Dave and I shared an office at Caltech. It's another interesting thing about him.
I have never been a smoker but he was and I told his story at meetings from people who asked
me about Dave, I said, well, you know, he didn't have an astray because that wouldn't have lasted
long. He had a French 75, how it's a shell casing, which is a brass thing with a rim on the bottom
and stood about two and a half feet high and I had a notch cut on the top and he'd stick you
sing a rep and that flip it in the ashes would come down. When he left, that thing was full of the
rim with ashes in my office. I threw it out of course but he gave up smoking right after that when
he went to MIT and Clara never smoked and she had some respiratory problems as well and so on
in her late years so it might have been part of the cause. They have a distinguished son,
Bobby Schumacher who went off to Britain and he's in a story young and he's at one of the
southwestern British universities and he believed it or not has a position
as a professor of English history. This is an American. He's still an American citizen and he's
written his thesis was a penetrating book, a penetrating document was his published in book form
and got very, very good reviews. So I think that's an interesting sideline to the
Schumacher's both scientists, the son of the historian, lecturing on any English history to
Brits and being academically rewarded for it. We've talked a little bit about
your early trips to Norway and your associations with Norwegian, and I wanted you to talk a little bit
more about how that has been seen every time you've mentioned Norway and Norwegian. Oh well,
let's see, I want to make sure that I'm talking about the things you would want me to
how I went to Norway and how my relationship with Norway and Norwegians continued professionally
through the years, is that? We've talked about the beginning of the trip, and how about what?
We talked about your initial trip to Norway and we knew it, of course, and then
yeah. You're really associations with other bastards and then you know how it has all
yeah, as well. My professional associations with Norway
developed as a consequence of knowing Professor Othol, Otholose Olsen,
the leader became director of the University. I don't remember whether I'd mentioned that or not,
but I was there. I spent, oh, I've lived in Norway probably about five years or so,
I'll told mostly in one year of stints, and by the way, polling has often told when I've been there,
and we escorted him around Boston and the various places in Norway and gone to meetings and talks
that he's home and that he held. That did he write? In Lisa's family connections, still early years
of our marriage were pretty strong, and she liked to go back to Norway. So, on my first
about I could leave, at Oregon State, I decided I would go back to Norway, we had some big projects
going on, that we could share in Norway with Norwegian colleagues, and so I spent a year at the
University of Los Roman, again, in Sebaticol, and Lisa worked also. She came in, and we had a nice house,
a range for our study on the University. Actually, it's a given one apartment, they don't have houses there,
by and large, for younger people. During this time, I met a number of people who were essentially
two laboratories doing my kind of work at the University of Oslo, and the other at
University of Trondheim, which didn't have that name at the time. One of Lisa's got her training
in Boston's laboratory, and a number of other people did, also one of whom was a lady named
Modet, Thutettabad, who went to Trondheim, became professor there, and I was invited up there
and gave a lecture, and she introduced me to a student of hers named Koldian Hagen, and Koldian
and I, the question was, he was so finishing his degree, and I was working for a full-stocked
associate, so I said to him, I said, well, he's pretty good, and yes, he's very good. So,
Koldian came to the United States. That was the beginning of a professional relationship.
I think that probably my strongest professional relationship, apart from that, of course,
it's my wife and the work that she does in the laboratory of anyone, and he has spent a total of six
years in Colorado. I was coming at various times for years leave, some once twice, two years
or leave, and so on. How did he start with me, just to make sure he did?
Hagen, H-H-E-M, and the first name is Koldian. Koldian is K-O-L, and B-J, umlauded, oh, R-M, that means
bear in the region. So, anyway, this relationship went on through the years, and then one time
I received an invitation, oh, I was at several times to serve on doctoral committees,
and one of them was Maddett's committee when she obtained her doctorate. That was quite early
in my career, and that was lots of fun, because it's all done very formally, you know, there's
a first opponent of second opponent, and then a third one is kind of a humorous opponent. So I was
the first opponent, and in these formal things, you're dressed very formally on the old days,
you used to wear tuxitos, the candidate would wear a salam, would wear a tuxedo. But we had a podium,
and the candidate was over here, bought it, and I was here, and there was an auditorium full
of people, and I had been given her thesis, and I would ask her questions, and she would answer,
and so on, and at the end, by the way, I was paid a substantial amount of money for this,
but that was a norm for the time. So we had a tremendous, the tradition is that the successful
candidate throws a party, and we had a wonderful, absolutely wonderful dinner party at her house,
a nutform and a association that continued until her death years later, but she's spent time
in Cornell's also. At any rate, so after my mid-career, when Collegard wrote me an informe,
that the university had elected to give me an honorary degree, so I could come up there,
and that was a tremendous fun also. There were three of us who were awarded an honorary degree,
and one of the guys was a fellow from Germany who had just won the Nobel Prize, so I felt myself
and distinguished company, and there was a big party, I still think of that great fondness.
And then, I think sometime before this, I was elected to membership in the Norwegian Academy of Sciences,
and a bit later, on another occasion, and a few years later, these are the American equivalents,
and the actual Norwegian name is, well, I don't have to describe it, but anyway, let's say,
one of them is the Norwegian calendar part of the National Academy of Sciences here,
and the other one is the Norwegian calendar part of the American Academy of Arts and Sciences,
and I've been asked, I've been awarded a membership in each one of these.
So all of this is a consequence of this long stretch of professional affiliation I've had with people in Norway.
I think the laboratory that does my kind of work in Oslo has now extinct,
and the one in the Trondheim is also, and everybody who has involved in my day just as I am, is retired.
And so the university efforts have gone off in different directions, but everyone that
belonged to this laboratory almost every single person at Oslo, I think borrowing one, has been
sometime in my laboratory, and almost everyone in Trondheim has also spent time in my laboratory.
So there's that number, so maybe 10 or 15 people altogether spent as long as two years
in my laboratory. I have a book in my office, in which I formed the early habit of taking a
pulmonary picture and pasting the book and asking them to sign their name to it, and all of these
people are there, and on one occasion when I was going to go to Norway, I was asked if I would
give a talk in Trondheim, and I said yes, and I got to thinking about this, so I called you in
hog and by this time I became a professor in Trondheim, so I pitched out all the pictures that I had
and arranged them in sequence from the time he first came, the time he last came, and they were about
heat of them, and I had a series of slides made of it, and I came to talk, I said, I want to
show you the history of one of our good friends, and so I put these up there, and to the
immense hilarity of the audience, because they'd never seen hog and as a young man, they'd always
seen it, and I could show his development with dates underneath. Well that made quite a hit on that
talk, he's never let me forget about that, even. So it's been a great boon and fun for me,
so I have also formed a professional attachment in friends with people at the University of Trondheim,
which is an annoying Norway, and at the University of Oregon, in the West Coast.
Well it's been a very fine thing for me.
I hear a list of names of people from the OSU permission department over the years, and when
they would be sharing your recollections, you have about something called John Fulton. John Fulton is the only
one that I never met in person. When I came to Oregon State in 1939, Gilbert was chair,
and I don't know how long he had been chairman at that point, but he certainly was still chairman
in 1956, when I returned. I think he actually retired from the German ship in 57. I wanted to
spend the last 30 years of his life as doing teaching and research again. That's when Christmas
looks excited in. So every, I don't know whether you've seen all the pictures and chemistry
had you. If you're going on the main hall, Gilbert Hall, on the end, nearest here at the library,
and walked down on the left-hand side high-op is a chronological arrangement of all professors
that have been present at this and that department and retired. John Fulton is the first one in the
list. Every single person I have known have a succeeding 20 or 30 up to 1 down the whole. Of course,
the last I've been retired long enough, so I'm quite a long way from the end now, but everybody
on, or to the president, I've known them all, except for them. That's what kind of we got that.
How about the fence board, Gilbert? Sorry, the fence board, Gilbert. You'll feel them again. Oh, yes, yeah.
He didn't have an active role in the chemistry department. He was Dean of the College of Science
and during the war for a short time, he was acting president of the university. I don't remember
this correctly, but he was a very, very dark man and a wonderful personality. I didn't know him well.
I met him on a number of occasions and he was still alive when I returned to the university,
but he suffered from, I don't remember whether it was Parkinson's or all. I think it was also
him, as he said, he finally succumbed to it, but he was just a wonderful guy. His family has set up
a research award in his name called the Guilfall on a prize. That's given every year to a faculty member.
Earl Gilbert. Earl Gilbert. The hall was not named Gilbert Hall until after he died,
because there was at that time a rule against naming buildings after living people.
Gilbert was a big guy. He walked with a kind of a shuffle. He was a physical chemist.
He had two sons, Henry and Alan, and Henry was a classmate of mine as an undergraduate.
In the war broke out, he was involved in warwork, or over in Albany. I don't know that it was
a Bureau of Minds and whether he was working with blockchain or whatever in the warwork.
But he died of a malignancy. People think it was related to ingestion and inhalation of
beraleum, which was extremely toxic. His son Alan Gilbert, I mean his brother, Alan Gilbert,
Earl Gilbert's son was a surgeon at the Coralis clinic many years. He retired as I understand it,
because he developed severe arthritis in his hands. He was a very nice guy.
Well, Gilbert, I had only one course from him when I was an undergraduate. The department's
chairman actually taught them, and he taught physical chemistry.
I recall one kind of plombient experience with Earl Gilbert when I was an undergraduate.
There was a chemistry on our society called Phyllandup Solom.
And I was elective membership in this, and Henry Gilbert, who was a chemistry major, was not.
Henry Gilbert was a, I want to say, a very pounce-boken outgoing guy. He was not elected
to, when you're elected to membership, a voter's taken. And if there is any, I don't recall
what the circumstances of the election, what the rules are or were at that time.
But he was not elected. And Earl Gilbert, his father, was very upset at this.
And he called me into his office and he says, I cannot ask you who he is in a very different way.
Let me know. I was very disappointed that Henry had not been elected. At that time, the chemistry,
the Phyllandup Solom had members comprising majors in chemistry and chemical engineering's large way.
And he says, I can't ask you, of course, about the vote, but he said, can you tell me this?
I suspect, was it mostly the engineers that were involved in this negative vote.
And I hesitated a long time when I said, well, you know, I felt like I had to answer it.
And I said, yes, it was. He just shrugged his shoulders. I know he deployed it.
There was a strong Greek community on the campus at the time that I was here.
There was a kind of a social division between the independence and the Greeks.
And that division seemed to extend into honor societies as well.
People were voted for membership. And you know, in retrospect, it's utterly ridiculous to think
that somebody who is academically well qualified would be not voted into an organization for personality reasons.
I like Henry Gilbert. We got along just fine. And he didn't have the shy, respectful attitude
that maybe these people expected he should have. But that was very upsetting to Earl Gilbert.
Another thing about the Gilbert, once a year, they invited the chemistry department to dinner at their house
with their faculty, with their spouses. And there was always a very nice dinner.
Now, the Gilbert's were Titovers. No alcohol was served.
Tomatoes were served instead. And that was all, oh, well, I'm good.
No, everybody understood this. Then the Gilbert's on off, I think it may have been one summer.
They took a trip to France. And they came back. And when I was slave all, a good friend of mine
was hosting a dinner party. And he asked the Lisa Nye where asked, we're invited as where the Gilbert's
and some other people in physical chemistry. And it was a very nice dinner. And when it'll ask me
ahead of time, he says, do you think I should offer people a cherry or a drink or wine with dinner?
And I said, well, it's your party. Why not? And the Gilbert's as I say, I just come back in this trip in France.
So, Wendel and Duke, of course, asked everybody what to read the forer and Earl Gilbert said,
well, I'll have a class of tomato juice. And his wife said, I think I'd like some cherry.
So, Gilbert wins. And she had a glass of cherry on the conversation with me. She said,
my that was nice. Sherry, I like that very much. And Gilbert modeled, and I like my tomato juice too.
I understood that I don't worry where I got this information, but I understood that,
as they traveled through France, they did drink wine because that's about the only thing that
you would be served at a meal. And maybe that's, oh, Mrs. Gilbert, just from a moment I can't remember
her name, but it'll come to me. They were nice people, I like them.
Will they express my analysis and will Wendel say well?
Oh, Wendel was a remarkable person. I held him in the highest regard, not when I first came, but later on.
He, um, um, when I first came, did I mention that there was, uh, I mentioned the Christmas
and became chairman after Gilbert, but that was not when I had a hitch in the proceedings.
Have I ever mentioned that? Well, for some gone forsaken reason, it was determined that the department
should, uh, not only elect, which was a reasonable enough, that should vote for who they would
propose a department chairman. Of course, that was non-binding because the dean is the one who makes a decision.
But one other thing for some reason, there's nobody seems to remember this, but me, I'll have to
dig out my records. The department decided it was going to have a constitution democracy with going to
rule. Now, if you think about that, how ridiculous can you imagine? You can't run a department
has a democracy with a legislature that determines things. You're going to have a department chairman.
The next things happen. The others at May, slave all ran for, uh, he came around and I was new
with this time, longer Tom Parsons. And, uh, I knew that he was a candidate. He came around
and, uh, in a very subtle way, was discussing this. And, uh, Christmasen was the era parent.
As I explained, uh, burnt shell on was a dean and they were good friends and everybody expected
that Christmasen, as they, as they, as the oldest and most experienced and long-served,
longest serving department member, would become chairman. He was a good scientist. He did
hard work and he's one of the few people who were regularly publishing at Oregon State at that time.
Well, slave all was running. Also, and, uh, there was determined that, uh, the person
who won the elections, name would go forward. Now, I don't remember whether
slave all won this election. I don't know how many votes were cast. Maybe 20, 12, 12, or 30,
won the election by one vote. And, hall hell broke loose. You know, uh, Christmasen was terribly
upset. And so, and, uh, as slave all told me later, he was invited, uh, over to, uh, a dean's office.
I don't know whether it was shell on and there's someone else. And sat down and talked to an
friendly matter, by this official, who pointed out that he was a young man, and that, uh, the
department would undoubtedly, uh, run better if somebody was long experienced whose chairman.
And as a young man, he would have plenty of chances to rise through the, uh, hierarchy into a
administrative position. And slave while reading the handwriting on the wall, just, uh,
then a now-city was withdrawing his name from consideration. That was his public statement,
but his private feelings I, uh, have relayed to you. So, Christmasen became chairman. And I think he always
said that, uh, well, I want to call it feeling of having been rejected, hanging over him for a
long time. So, he stole very hard to be what he thought would be a good chairman. And I could
tell you about that also, but slave on was a distinguished teacher. His lectures were very popular.
And he had a most original mind. Uh, he, uh, he did unusual things. He built himself, uh,
was rare at that time, a three-wheeled bicycle with, uh, enclosed in, uh, uh, uh, a canopy over the top,
which had, uh, plastic windows in front, so he was shielded from the wind. And he would pedal this
thing to work. Now, a little flag up the back. This is it. You see some of the handicapped people using these
today. Not him. He had this. Later on, he built something similar. And he put a motor on it.
It was electric motor and operated by a battery. He built it all himself. He lived on, uh, on Grant Street,
uh, up about, uh, 30 fourth street on the right-hand side. And he had hedges there. And he trimmed these hedges.
So, what is the art form known when you cut these in the form of shapes and animals? He meticulously
groomed these plants. And he had one sitting there that had wheels on it. And a canopy and a steering wheel.
Just one bush that had been sculpted into that shape. Others, he sculpted into animal shapes.
And then in his driveway, which sloped down to the street, he painted one of the very famous, uh,
oh, what's the guy's name who does these peculiar drawings? Their famous, now he's the famous artist,
the water that runs uphill without sending to do this. Yes, sir. Yes, sir. He painted the black and white
dogs that, you know, mesh together and are going down to the sidewalk. He built outside, uh,
a bench into the wall. His yard sloped down to a concrete area there. And he built a bench in there,
a wood. And it says, uh, I don't remember the Italian words exactly, or the pronunciation, but
he said, and since it's something, come although they're public or for the convenience of
the public, he said. We got to know him and his wife very well, uh, later on, we saw them socially
a good deal. And, uh, Laws' wife was a very nice lady. Uh, Wendell, uh, he had this nice house.
He had an idea. He went down to the GT one time and he bought or brought, I think he was
they were given to him a number of, uh, plates, which were used in printing, which were all black
on the top. They were, uh, perhaps, uh, glass or something. I don't know. But he bought a whole bunch of
these and he built himself a box on his roof and he mounted these things to the sunwood hit it
and he slowly circulated air through this, which he then arranged to be pumped down into his house.
And, uh, you still have to have a furnace, of course. But he said this, uh, noticeably
reduces heating costs. Then in later years, he would quit early and he says, I need some
exercising, we'd go home and I discovered he was digging a huge sister in his yard.
And, uh, I saw this thing being constructed and he had great lines in back too. Wasn't a big yard,
but he had great lines as well. And, when this was completed, you know, we were up there a
dinner one time, since come and see my sister and it was just completed. And I looked down in this
down thing. It was about eight feet across and it was at least eight feet tall. It was a huge
thing and he dug it all by hand, made the lining and everything and it's concreteed at all up
and so on. And, he said, uh, there it is. He says, I'm going to start filling it and he says,
let's go down and he had a ladder built on the side. So we went down, we sat down on a
couple chairs in the bottom. We'll even describe this sister into me. So then we went upstairs
and he covered it and he typed all the water that fell on his roof, all of that went into the
sister, which he then pumped out to water, he's garden. The front lawn and the vines and back,
everything. And then the city then had an assessment for storm for drainage. So we went down to
the city and said he wanted to have his drainage reduced because the property was not as big as
they said it was and he gave him an estimate of a score footage of the roof on his house and he
wanted to proportional reduction in his drainage sheet. The city would have nothing to do with this.
At which point he realized that this drainage was really a tax on the amount of land that you had,
not really on, it's disguised the way he put it to me. So that was window.
He died of a heart attack and he's asleep and there's tragic thing, the lowest was very upset
and she continued to live in the house for quite a while and she would come to our house regularly
and we would go up there to dinner and she came to us for dinner and I did some work,
a little work in our house for. I repaired the toilet that was leaking around the seam at the
bottom, put a new boat, boot in it and I drilled a hole in a door and put one of these view ports in it
for a few things like that and she developed an infection that when a time it was diagnosed her
condition was so poor that she even after treatment, she couldn't recover and she eventually died
from it, not the infection but the fact that she had no reserves left. So that's the story of
the slaves, as I know, they had one son who isn't California still, he has no children and he is an
orthopedic surgeon. He had a daughter named Jane, who babysat our kids when they were small and
she became for a reason, so it was never entirely clear to me a strange from her mother and she lives
in Seattle. She was married and then divorced and I think I've seen her once up there but I don't
know what's become of her since then. That's about what I know of the slave laws.
You've made some great business in there, did you find Jane?
Oh, yes. Well, Burton very much wanted people to realize that convince people he was a very good
department chairman and we have an chemistry department at that time. We have a source of
chemicals. Let's call it a store room. There are a lot of chemicals used at that time in organic
chemistry and so on. There's a big supply in there and he would buy these in bulk and they would be
repackaged in jars and labeled with a number and so on on them and other departments, you know,
it couldn't afford a store room like this. This would be sold to them at the price that was
less or maybe just a trifle less of a price listed for the same size container of the same material
in the drug and chemical scallot. And by buying it both, when we're packaging it, we save money,
you made money and that money was used to support various things. After realized on those days,
there was almost no money for anything. You wanted to replace the equipment, you know,
there's like pulling teeth to get any money from the university for that. And this enabled things
to proceed in the department and to keep us at least hanging on. The trouble with this was
that this money, which went into a call, had to be spent by the 30th of June. And sometimes
persons were very frugal. He would get all this stuff piled up there and then he didn't have
a way of spending it before the end. So all sorts of peculiar things happened. He came down to me
one time and says, can, how do you like to have your office painted? I said, my office painted,
I don't need my office painted, and he says, well, you know, it's a little dingy in here.
We should paint through these offices and I just shrugged in. So my office was painted and that
used up some of the money. On another occasion, he was walking down the hall and the basement.
He says, you know, I don't like the look of all these pipes over ahead. This, in the basement,
everything was open all sorts of vents and pipes that look terrible. He says, I think, how would you
react to the idea that we put a false ceiling in a mask-built list of? I said, well,
can do it if you want. I don't see the need for it. In fact, it improves the appearance of things
for it also makes it substantially more difficult to locate the source of problems. So in
due course we have that false ceiling, which if you're going to the basement of Gilbert, you can see
it's still there. It's got holes punched in it. It's white panels suspended from the ceiling.
So Burke was very, very conscious of how I want to say. He seemed to be covering his tracks
all the time. And one of the reasons that he refused to renew my wife's appointment had nothing at
all to do with science. Anything like that, she was paid very modestly on any of that. But for the
first time in history, just before he took this action, the city of Coralis defeated upon
measure designed as support schools. And he thought, boy, people are looking at what the education
system is doing and here they're going to see that there's a faculty member of why it was being
paid on a faculty member being paid through the system. Of course, my grants were to the
university and they were paid. And he decided he couldn't tolerate a possibility of somebody objecting
to this. And that was the reason that he advanced to me. He says, we have to be very careful of our
image. He advanced to Lisa. I didn't have any new in it. She wrote him a letter, went to see him,
wrote him another letter, and nothing. Finally, he refused to answer her letters, and that's when
we went over to the dean. But I remember a remarkable Gilbert said, one time, he was a gruffle
guy and he spoke down like he says, he says, he says, he says, bird is sort of like a country horse.
He shies it a paper in the road. So that's Mark. He contributed after he retired, you know,
he sent up a fund designed to help graduate students attend meetings when they were working
in research with research groups for which there was no money. And that was used to a quite
lot. And I thank him a couple of times when I saw him on the streets. And he says, oh well,
I'm pleased. He says, if you need more money, let me know. And I don't know whether he put more money
up or not. I was not going to be fine with gentlemen. So yeah, he's good sides.
So that's an instrument, gentlemen. I don't remember much about burn on the same personal
element basis that mentioned these other people because he was sitting in the dean's office
at the time. Well, when I first came here, he was sort of something who was ahead of something
called the Research Institute. And it turned out, in the early days, there was the group of
biochemists associated with chemistry. Among who was Schell alumnum. And he decided that he would
like to set up this independent entity. There were lots of reasons for it because overhead
that was returned to these agencies. At that time, the university returned part of the overhead
to the departments. And the departments then to determine how they were going to use this returned
overhead. Well, I think burn had some ambitions. But clearly he did. He was a nice guy,
by the way. He arranged, I'm sure, with the support of Chris and Santa, take these biochemists
to set up what they call the science research institute, which is largely biochemistry.
And then later on, that became, I think, kind of morphed into a longer perhaps,
other departments, I'm not quite sure, and the department about chemistry and biofysics.
And then, uh, burn became the department, the department. He suffered from health problems,
serious ones. He had, uh, very high blood pressure at one stage, and he died really rather young.
His life was, uh, very well known, also, um, was that I read the name on the range of women.
But I think she served, uh, she was certainly involved in local politics.
And I don't know whether, uh, she'll have a middle school as, uh, they were philanthropic also.
Whether that followed mostly from her work or from them jointly as the couple, but at any rate.
So, uh, that's about as much as I know, burn.
First, I see one of the street with shake hands and shout a bit, and then I had this,
at least, and I had this contact with him in the occasion of her appointment. That's about all we had to do with him.
Yeah, that's what my list is, Kelvin.
Oh, Carol, the cock? Yeah. Oh, Carol is a wonderful guy.
I, I regard him as one of the, certainly one of the better Germans that I have, uh, experienced here.
Carol had a research program in, uh, in organic chemistry when I first came.
And, uh, he decided he would, uh,
whatever reason. I think his research was slowing down that he would, uh, run for department,
German German, and, uh, uh, I think that there were two choices. One of them was, uh,
Gerrit Thomas, and the other was Carol, and I think the ultimate decision was made by the dean,
that it would be Gerrit Thomas, and after he served for a term, Carol became department, German.
Now, Carol, he really ran the department the way that a lot of us would like to see it done.
He once professed him, he says, look, he says, my research days have over, I view my role in this department,
as to expedite the research and teaching potential of the department to the maximum, uh, possible.
And so he was no, uh, the difference between him and the Christmas and say to choose an example.
Christmas, and you couldn't probably a dime out of him, uh, until then, when you saw this
flamboyant expenditures being made, I'd go to Carol and I'd say, look, I need some money from my
return overhead, by the way. In those days, the department received returned overhead from the
university, maybe they still do, I don't know, but the department to determine how well they
did with the overhead and our department of the practice of returning about 80% of the overhead
that was derived from the research grant of an individual to that individual.
So if you had a big research grant, I'll put you a lot of overhead was extracted,
returned to the department, then you would have a chunk of money to deal with, because I think they
returned 80% or so, and you could use that anyway you want. Now, what happened was that an order
should be said about that returned overhead was now available and you should write down what your
needs are. Now, wasn't that the overhead was directed specifically to the individual who had
earned it, but that would receive some priority, but a lot of us didn't need all of them overhead,
and so we build up formally speaking and account. Other people who needed equipment that exceeded
the return overhead could use the return overhead, and then you would have a credit so to speak.
Well, of course, it's not a business, and looking back at perspectives and the visual
would have seen that this can't persist, and the guys who have the credits are probably
never going to realize their money back again, whereas those guys who are in debt, you know,
the department's going to decide they're not going to distribute overhead anymore, and so they
come out swimming like a rose. Well, I didn't need all of my money, because I was saying,
I had equipment budgets, and I could buy any equipment and apparatus that I needed. But Carol,
when I went to him on a couple of occasions saying, I need this, or I need that,
Carol, and I don't have the money in my budget for it. He says, how much is it? I'd tell him.
He'd look at this and say, okay, go ahead, buy it. And he was very effective in this way,
and I think people respected him for that, because people didn't go to him to try to buy things
that really didn't need. And this was in keeping with his professed remark to me, his remark to me,
that he was going to do what he could to expedite the teaching and research activities of the
department. If you needed money for your research, and you didn't have it, he tried to get it for you.
He was very good. He's still around. We have an old man's lunch once a month. Did you know that?
The old man's lunch started way, way back in 1986, and it started with a bus marvel,
Elliott Marvel, a professor of organic chemistry, who retired and jacked issues, and it may have been
Harry front also there, decided they would meet for lunch. And then there were probably four of them all told,
and then when I retired, they decided that I would be invited to this, and then it became a kind
of a monthly affair. And as people have retired, that has kept going. So every retiree in chemistry,
and two or three in Bach, chemistry involved as the Chris Matthews comes, can then hold as a part of it.
Bob Becker comes, and several chemists come. Several chemists who could come don't because
their active tennis players still, and they had matches Wednesday at noon when we have our meetings
once a month. But I go regularly. And so Carol, the co-comps. And he's a very lively guy.
It's also fun to see him. He's been very active. He bought a house on a teoria road. He's been an active
co-actor for years. And finally, he decided that the commute for him and his wife was just too
much, so they sold out property, at least in the process of selling it, and bought some last year
here in town, where he's now living. But he still co-acts. In fact, they went down the road recently,
and he's been down the Grand Canyon more than once than his own co-act. So he's very active physically.
Wonderful guy.
What are some of the more crippled, crippled, remember, all the things you said about things here,
what the strategy is to use?
A memorable experience is working with graduate students. Well, I'm thinking here as I'm sitting.
I've had some very good graduate students, and some that were not so good.
Almost all of whom have finished and gotten a degree.
Let me name one who came along fairly late. His name was Chen Fan Huang.
And he was a Chinese national, and he came here when all I'd have to look to see, but it's been
almost 20 years now. Perhaps even more than that. From China,
when it was still a highly restricted place, and he grew up in time of the cultural revolution
by his own bootstrapped, lifted himself up. And he became aware of a position I had,
and I don't remember the details, but I decided he would be a good addition.
And I think he was coming at the beginning with his own money.
So he arrived. I had several students working with me at that time.
And one of these was a young woman that was working away when he showed up, and I happened to be
away that day he arrived. He came into the laboratory. This young woman was trying to do some work
on her computer, and he spoke a rather poor English at this time, but he was as
young whole as they could come. And after a while, I think a day or two later, this girl came
to me. And so I can't stand this guy. She says, over my shoulder, all the time, ask me also. It's
a question. He was so eager. Well, by this time I was taking him in hand myself, and he was
beginning to enroll in courses. And he was very anxious to start research. And he was dynamic.
He was a tremendous researcher. And he was an older man. And he had had a lot of work in chemistry,
even at the theoretical, that was very knowledgeable. But he was required to fulfill
our department requirements, of course, for course, work. And he enrolled in theoretical chemistry.
And he got straight A's, no question about it. At the end of his first year, he is
old at the outstanding incoming graduate student. And then a year later he was old at the
outstanding graduate student. And each of these carried financial stipends, not a great deal,
but some. And one day he came to me and said, you know, the Chinese are very cognizant of
let's say of a social hierarchy on the reference, which should be paid to people who occupy a
state as a little more elevated than yours. And so he came to me having just attended
lecture in quantum mechanics by one of our faculty members. And he said to me,
quote, he said, is it all right to correct a professor when he's wrong?
And I said, yes it is. You should tell him or raise the issue and tell him about it and say
that you think this is the right answer. But I'm not quite sure that he ever followed through on that.
Well, he did a lot of work. And then at the end of his graduation, he got his degree.
He worked for a while with Doug Kessler in chemistry. And then a colleague of mine at Michigan named
Larry Bartel was looking for somebody and I recommended Jim Wong to him. And of course, he shows up
and Larry isn't doing quite the same kind of work that I am. And Larry has a very abrasive
no nonsense personality. But I think he met his match in Genre and Huang, because he would tell
Huang to do something and Huang would do it, but then he would point out he could do it better this
way and he would do it that way. So it turns out that Huang was married and he could hardly wait
to get his wife to come to this country. And finally, he arranged so that she could come.
And they had two children, two boys, which is, of course, out of the line there.
At any rate, the first thing that did, the woman came, he wanted her here so she could cook and he
could spend more time doing research. And he enrolled his son in the high school as elder son.
I guess both kids, but I don't remember so much about the younger. Anyway, he was very distressed
because after a while, the younger son was not rushing home after school and spending the rest of the
afternoon studying. The son became quite used to American manners and he liked the social life
and so on and just distressed his father immensely, expected him to behave like a Chinese.
So he came to me with his problem and I said, Genre, and I said, how's your son doing? Well,
he could do better. He could come home and he could be studying advanced things and I said,
well, how are his grades? He said, what grades? I said, well, what are the marks he gets?
The course of the thesis, when they get so old age. So it wasn't an upper-gen fund that his kid was
excelling by Americans standards. He had to study all of his spare time and see. Well, the things went on,
his wife had to go home or he's expired and then he learned after she'd been home a long time
that she was pregnant. At which time he immediately divorced her? That's unknowable there,
you see. And I think I don't know whether his sons had gone back or whether they stayed with him
here or not. I just don't remember that. But then he began to look for a new wife.
And this is kind of a mail order proposition. And so I don't know how the Chinese do it traditionally,
but there's any rate he found some woman in Shanghai. He went to visit her and I think they
eventually married. And she's a little more modern type than he was. And she joined even
Minnesota and I think they're still there. I don't know whether they have any children together or
enough. But he found a job in an industry and an arbor, but he still works weekends in Larry
Bartell's laboratory. So he's the most notable graduate student from several points of view that I've
had. I've had postdocs that are even just as remarkable one from Japan in particular. We're
getting on here. How long do you want to go? I can go a while longer. Let me talk about one of my postdocs.
I mean, I have a host of graduate students and each one of those has got his own personalities
and some have been very productive, some less productive. But I want to mention something
that I think is remarkable life or a pair of lives. There was a distinguished professor named
Yonaiso Morino, Morino in Japan, at the University of Tokyo. And in 1960, I think it was
60 at land in 62. But at any rate, I had a letter or a roll letter. I was looking for a postdoctoral
pointer, pointy. And Yonaiso was called Morino. We became friends and I've seen him all over the
world of meetings in Norway and other places. He wrote to me about his student named Machio
He was hockey. Who would like to study and he could recommend him. Now, Machio came to the United
States, having gotten his doctorate in Japan and he was phenomenal. He was a superb mathematician
and an excellent experimentalist. He had only rudimentary English, but I spoke slowly and he
could understand me and I could understand him. Well, it turned out that when you knew he would
come here the United States in three months, he'd had no English experience at all. He, and of course,
he had essentially no money. They don't have money at his graduate students in Japan at that time.
And so he went in hawk and enrolled in a course in Crash Course in English language.
And he managed to get enough English so that he could speak to me in English in three months
time. Now, that's very, it's not so hard for Western speaking person to do that, but Japanese
is so different that it's a tour of course. He became much better as time went along.
So he asked me to find a helping find a place to live, which I did and it was very
satisfactory. It was very low level, but after all, he was here to do research. He had his wife
with him, had no children. And a few weeks later, he came to me, he said, did I know a doctor?
He said, well, what's the problem? He says, my wife is terrible pains in her legs and so on.
And we better see a doctor. And so I gave him the name of a doctor that we had used for kids.
And it came to me the next day and he said, oh, I didn't need the doctor. He solved the problem.
The problem was that never in Japan had this woman been sitting in chairs.
She had always been in the Japanese traditional position on her knees and legs with her feet
back like this. The minute she started to do that, all her pains disappeared.
So she could sit on the chairs intermittently and sooner or later, the problem vanished.
Another time it came to me and says, I need to have vitamins. You know where I can get vitamins.
I says, oh, yeah, you can find them in any store. And he then told me, well, he didn't mean that.
And I said, well, what kind of vitamins do you mean? He says, I want that. He says, I take vitamins,
but I inject them. And I say, well, people don't inject vitamins here. You can take them all away.
And then another time he came to me and said that, well, you spent a year.
Then he asked me if he could continue another year. And I said, yes, of course you can't.
So he worked very hard. And then he came to me at that year and he said, I've been thinking about another apartment.
I said, and he said, I would like to have you join me and look at it.
So it was over on Western Avenue, or he had been living on 11th Street in an old brick building,
there with the apartment building. And so this place was lighter and more airy and it seemed to me
I'm like a nice place and it was cheaper. And he seemed very hesitant about it and he kept looking at me.
And then sometime later he said, you wouldn't lose face if I'm on terror.
Apparently on his mind because it was cheaper, it was a downgrade and quality when
matter of fact it was an upgrade and quality. But what is remarkable about this is his having been
raised in the time, maybe it's still of where face is everything.
Well, the story is incomplete without my telling you a little bit about his wife who is even more
remarkable. She couldn't take English, she knew no English, and she came here.
She came from a fairly well-off Japanese family, very Western, who are as much as family
was very traditional. His father was an old sea captain. And the daughter-in-law was expected to
do everything in the house, they lived. Anyway, she did housework for no pay with the stipulation
that the person for whom she worked would speak only English to her and try to help her
understand the English language. And that went on for months, and she became conversational
in English in a whole thing way. Then, Monsho said after his first hearing says,
now I want to buy a car, I want a car. So he passed the driver's license,
I think he failed at once, then passed it, both the written and so on. Many's wife said she
wanted one, but she couldn't read English. She could only speak it. And of course, I give you
this manual with all the written instructions, what the signs mean, everything. She looked at
the manual and this is how she memorized everything in the manual. She went and took the written
exam and got 100% on it without being able to read any words other than stop and slow and knowing
what the signs meant. The other things she did to her and money, they wanted extra money.
See, so she heard herself out from the strawberry seat and came around to pick strawberries.
That was a big thing in those days. And she picked strawberries about twice as fast as anyone else
because she knew how to sit on her home. She could do a line like a rabbit according to my
other signs. She could pick these strawberries and they were paid peaceways. She made more money than
anyone else picking strawberries. Well, they went back to Japan. I visited them there on a
most remarkable experience one time, but I'll tell you what happened to her. They moved in with
his parents and she had to play the subservient daughter on what I was there with a friend and
revisited them. We were invited to the old people's house and they were kimonos and as we came
in the door, we were professors. My friend and I and Macho was we finished the travel. That's
another story. They were on their knees, you know, with their heads down like this because we were
professors and we were assured in. But Motico, the wife of Macho, did not eat dinner with us.
She served as she was in the kitchen all the time. After the parents died and they took over
the house, she began to do watercoloring. And as time wand, her watercolors became very well-known
and then finally she became famous. When she died some years ago now, not many,
maybe five. She was the most talked about watercolors than all of Japan. They're paintings
are in museums and she made lots of money from her pain. Just an utterly remarkable couple.
I feel very fortunate to have known them. So that's he's the most remarkable postdoctoral
person I've had from these, I'm other people of scientifically excellent. Of course,
that's not really what I'm talking about. But in addition to the scientific excellence that
Macho had, he had all of the other things. They saved money while away here so they could buy
an American hot water heater and send it home and install in his parents' house so they would
have hot water. And when I came to visit them, they were very worried about toilet facilities
because they only had the traditional thing for a couple of porcelain raised footprints on a
hole in the floor and you had the squat you see. So remarkable insight into Japanese living.
The occasion of this, I can tell you this visit to Japan with Macho,
all the votes Johnson, whom I mentioned before and I were in Japan for a meeting.
And preliminary to that meeting, we were asked by Macho or by some other the principal
sir, would we, would you like to do something ahead of time and I wrote and said yes,
we would like to look around Japan a bit a week ahead of time and there was a range that
Macho had a car now, it was employed by an institute and becoming a very well-known son of this,
we took this around in this car. And the one thing I said to him is that I didn't want to live in
any American, excuse me, or English style accommodations. And so I wanted to see what
Japan and particularly a rural Japan would like. So as we traveled around for seven days,
he had booked ahead of time, accommodations and Japanese ends. And all the time we were
traveling on this trip, I never saw another Caucasian in these ends in which we stayed.
We would come in, there would be a doorstep, we would be met with the hostess who would bow
and give us our kimono, you know, and take off our shoes, we would be ushered to our room
and some sort of small snuck bits after our travel would come. And then a few minutes later,
the person would come in and say, your bath is ready. The bath was not a char. It was a huge
place, this was more or less the norm. And there was a huge tub, it was about four feet deep,
and it would hold four or five people. And it was full of scalding water and you see it.
Then there, away from this tub, it's a tiled area with soap along the wall, and there's where
you wash yourself very thoroughly and rinse yourself, then you got into the tub to soak.
Then after a while, you'd get out again and repeat the process. That's what a Japanese,
that's what we were treated to. Well, then we got out and we were sort of,
how do you want to call totally relaxed with all of this? We're going to come on over, we came back in.
This was a Japanese room, no beds, nothing, you know, tautami on the floor, a rice door,
and then there would be the discreet knock and the horses would come in,
or one of the serving girls would come in and come on, bowing like this, set up a little table,
put the stuff on it, and sit there, and serve us, pour the sake for us. And my Japanese
we didn't begin a Japanese, of course, but my Japanese friend Macho would translate and he says,
if we like the service, we are, it is part of the process to offer her a drink of sake.
And so we did that and she bowed gracefully and drank sake very nicely. And then at the end,
they would plural us away and then they would haul out the tautami that you were going to sleep on,
bed, so to speak, the role, and that would be put out on the mat on the floor.
And there we would sleep. And at the end of every one of these rooms was a glass partition that
opened on to a private, very small, not bigger than this room, Japanese garden, beautifully planted with plants.
We went around a number of these places and on one occasion on a Saturday night, you know,
the Japanese, they're way out on the countryside. The men leave their family, they go out there and they have
drunken orgies. And one of these places we were on the second floor and I looked out the window
in the morning and on this beautiful green lawn, we're a number of recumbent forms sound asleep,
you know, where they had collapsed after a night of drinking inside. But Japanese don't look
at drunkenness in the same way that we do. I've walked through Kyoto and there will be a guy
lag on the sidewalk. The tops come along and very carefully, picking up by the armpits,
dragging up to the wall and probably moped right there and then walk on. Well, that's about as much as I
can tell you about that. But that trip is something few Americans have ever experienced and
when I came back to Tokyo, Machio said, you know, if Lisa had come with you, we would have had none
of this service because she would have been expected to perform it. I told my wife that she said,
it's good she didn't come along. Well, I think the thing that I've most
proud of Chris is that I've had what I think is a very happy life and what I've done.
My childhood was, I won't say actually, I'm published, but we lived through the depression
on the portion of which my father was all to work and the notion that I would have been able
to do the things that I have been able to do would have been almost something above. For example,
I've traveled all over the world. I've made much more money than my father ever did and I have
kids that are successful and I've had wonderful colleagues and I've had a research career that
has kept me occupied even to date. I don't think I could have planned it any better actually
if I'd had to set out ahead of time. On the other hand, when you look back on a long life,
you see that there are certain points where you've made decisions that in retrospect you're very
happy with, but at the time it was almost a flip of the kind. For example, I very nearly married
somebody else before I met Lisa and decided not to. It was touching go. My whole life would have
been different. I wouldn't have had any of the same connections, and Lisa's gifted scientist.
I wouldn't have had anywhere near the career I've had were it not for the many contributions
that she's made to it. We sat down last night and had a conversation about a problem I'm
having and we came to a conclusion about it. How it is. I don't know whether I mentioned this,
maybe I did when I got my full ride on Google and I'm fellow ships to Norway. The previous year
I had applied for a full ride fellowship. The application was received to late. If I'd gotten it,
which I was led to believe I would have, if I'd been received in time, I would have gone to Belgium.
I would never have had any of this Norwegian connection. My life would have been totally different.
Except for that week or so delay and getting the application in. When you're an old man like
me, you can think back on these career changing decisions that you made. All in all, I would say
that I just have a very happy life. It's still happy except I see my friends falling one by one.
That's the pressing experience. But come through us all.
Yeah, well, I've enjoyed it.